انا من الناس اللي انعزلت ثلاث ايام
وانضربت انضربت يعني وعلم على بدني ثلاث
ايام واصريت اني اروح على العياده وافرج
الدكتوره وكتبت تقرير بهذا الشيء لاني
كثير بقيت تعبانه وعندي سكري وضغط وعندي
مرض بالقلب يعني صابتني ازمه قلبيه مرتين
وانا بالسجن سيد احمد جرادات ووراءه ليست
قصه واحده عده قصص انت زوج الاسيره عطاف
جرادات الاسيره ام الاسرى ايضا انت والد
الاسرى عمر وغيث و منتصر كيف تعيش هذه
التجربه اجمالا نحن نعيش يعني بظروف قاسيه
وصعبه جدا جدا نحن مشتتين عندي طفلان طفله
يعني اسرت امها واخ اخوتها الثلاثه وهي
كانت عمرها 14 سنه
و يعني وابن المقدام راغب كان عمره 15 سنه
وكان مصاب واجره معاك مشلوله وعلى يعني لا
و على الحركه عندما تقلت امه واسرت امه
والان نحن مشتتون من يومها الى الان نفتقد
يعني ام المنتصر المراه التي لم يعني يكون
هناك مثيل لها في الكرم والباع الطويل
والنشاط والجد والاجتهاد صاحبه اللمات
الكريمه لاولادها
وبناتها
واحفادها يعني زوجتي هي اكبر الاسيرات
عمرها و 52 سنه وعندها 21 حفيد وتسع اولاد
سته من الذكور وثلاثه من البنات كل
المصائب والابتلاءات التي نزلت بنا لو
نزلت على جبال نزلت على جبال لهدها لكننا
محتسبون صابرون وكل ذلك يهون في سبيل الله
وفي سبيل فلسطين والقدس والاقصى ماذا لو
حدثت المشاهد الكريم وضعته في صوره اعتقال
زوجتك الكريمه سيده عطاف يتهمون اغيث الله
بقيام بعمليه حومش هو وخاله الشيخ محمد
جردات وابن خالي محمود جردات ابو ساجد لكن
ماذا عن عطاف ماذا عن سيده عطاف عطاف يعني
اتهموها انها كانت تعلم تعلم وان قامت
بتوزيع حلوى ليله الاعتقال ووصل الامر الى
يعني المتدينين والمستوطنين وطالبوا بقصف
بيتي وتدميره على رؤوسنا وقتل زوجتي هل
تمكنتم من زياره عطاب نعاني كثيرا بالنسبه
للزيارات لا يجد احد منا مع تصريح جميع
اولادي والثلاثه وزوجتي لا احد زورهم لا
زوجاتهم ولا انا ولا بناتي ولا قسم من
اولادي اللي خارج
[موسيقى]
السجن